[Music]
on this Friday night the Prime Minister
visits BC's Wildfire Zone
his promise to the province and the
Northwest Territories that we will
continue to be there to support the
proactive measures smaller communities
want the feds to take
insurance companies face increasing
demand Canada has definitely becoming a
riskier place to operate the fears among
Canadian customers
and scowling after surrendering I did
nothing wrong the captivation and
political capitalization of this
historic mugshot
global national with paranasser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us we begin tonight with a Bittersweet
homecoming for BC evacuees a week after
apocalyptic wildfires tore through the
Okanagan region some people are back
home tonight but some don't have a place
to go back to as more evacuation orders
lift prime minister Justin Trudeau also
touched down in the region today meeting
with local officials for the first time
since the province declared a state of
emergency last Friday
now while a sense of relief is
blanketing many parts of the province
many are still in danger Nathan Garcia
begins our coverage from West Kelowna
as fire Crews conduct more controlled
Burns near West Kelowna smoke is visible
on the Mountainside below that
Mountainside prime minister Justin
Trudeau making comments at the local
fire hall we are going to continue to be
there as a federal government in
supporting whether it's with the
Canadian Armed Forces whether it's with
Federal supports but Trudeau while
reinforcing ottawa's commitment to help
fell short of making any new
announcements including for the
Northwest Territories where 70 percent
of the population has been evacuated for
several weeks we will continue to be
there to support as people are facing
the challenges of of returning and
rebuilding in some cases the Prime
Minister also visited officials at the
West Bank First Nation government
offices I brought my daughter Ella after
introducing his daughter Ella Grace who
shook hands and briefly spoke with the
local leaders the Prime Minister met
with some of those involved in the
Region's Wildfire response
demanded over here originally jumped
across the lake our firefighters save
thousands of homes I'm among them is the
mayor of the District of Lake Country
trying to find moments of normalcy after
homes were destroyed and evacuation
orders are still in place he says with
climate change making extreme weather
events more frequent the federal
government needs to step up with
infrastructure funding for smaller
communities to support people in times
like this the road networks having
enough water to fight the fire fire
smarting communities of the federal
government
it's time to stop our communities having
to beg for Grants all the time and come
to us with stable and constant funding I
think we need to start looking at that
around emergencies we certainly need to
look at that around infrastructure
Investments so that cities can make the
plans to continue to grow notable
progress on the fires helped ensure more
residents could return home Friday but
there is still a very active fire fight
which officials say is far from Over the
federal minister of emergency
preparedness announced today BC's
request for more assistance from the
Canadian Forces has been approved with
members on their way to help with
firefighting operations in areas like
this pharah
meetu garcha on West Bank First Nation
thank you nitu and a couple hours north
of Kelowna and BC's shoe swap region a
section of the trans-canada highway that
was closed has reopened today after
being closed due to wildfires for the
past week officials are stressing that
drivers will not be able to stop along
the stretch of road to see the heavy
damage from the Bush Creek East Wildfire
a big chunk of that damage belongs to
the nearby little shoe swamp Lake First
Nation
we lost a lot you know
31 houses I think was the latest count
it could climb
yeah we lost houses but
the important thing
that house doesn't become a home unless
family is in there or not and everybody
from the community was got out safely
and later in the newscast you're going
to hear from those in the shushwap
region who are still fighting the
wildfires that are threatening their
homes
now climate change is spurring disaster
after disaster and cleanup is costing
Canadians more each and every year
homeowners and insurance companies are
tallying up the enormous price tag from
this historic Wildfire season which is
likely into the billions by now and
because of it premiums are going up and
now there are some concerns that
insurance companies May one day pull out
of some areas altogether Sharia Israeli
reports
wildfires
tornadoes
flooding this summer has been extreme
expensive and exhausting oh my God a
tornado just hit our house Canadians
across the country are spending hours
dealing with insurance companies so
everything's a right off but they told
us it'll probably be months before
everything's addressed a torrential
downpour hit Ottawa this month Christine
Fagan lost her car insurance has been
doing what they can I guess they're
really slammed
they're getting more slammed every year
in 2010 Canadian insurance companies saw
losses of 632 million dollars annually
now that number is more than three times
higher last year losses totaled almost
three and a half billion and 2023 is on
track to be even costlier well insurers
price risk and Canada is definitely
becoming a riskier place insurance
premiums Rose between 5 and 15 percent
this year with some of the biggest
increases in Alberta and BC for
homeowners who have filed repeated
claims how many times have you been
flooded on the street at least five
there are fears they could be dropped
altogether like a good neighbor State
Farm is there State Farm recently pulled
out of California because of the
Relentless wildfires for now Canadian
risk management experts doubt that will
happen here I think there are a lot of
actions being taken to try to ensure we
don't get there but
I I think it is a long-term concern
researchers say insurance is only one
part of the puzzle homes in Canada need
to become more resilient to the effects
of climate change and that means
changing the way they're built the
system's a little slow in Canada Glenn
McGillivray manages the institute for
catastrophic loss reduction he wants to
see more incentives for Builders to
flood and fireproof homes there's
already a huge shortage of homes we
can't afford to be taking hundreds and
sometimes thousands of homes offline at
each year due to hazards hazards in a
climate crisis that's also creating a
financial one
Global News Ottawa
it's also been a full week since
wildfires forced thousands to leave
their homes in the Northwest Territories
and there the fire fight is far from
over today the territories Premiere
along with Alberta's Premier visited an
evacuation Center in Calgary that city
is hosting more than 2 700 evacuees
68 percent of our population has been
evacuated many of the people in the
north have never left the north they're
not familiar with big cities I know it's
a struggle myself I had to evacuate as
well and the amount of people that were
standing on the roads giving out gift
cards opening their homes and in a
watering things I can't express how how
much gratitude and how much it meant to
us
evacuees are staying at 48 hotels around
the city with no word on when they'll be
able to go back home
joining us now from the Northwest
territory's Capital is the mayor off
Yellowknife Rebecca alte mayor thanks
for being with us I know it's been an
unimaginable week and I can see you're
still in your office in Yellowknife so
what does the town feel like and how
close is the fire compared to this time
last week
yeah so it is
um it's been a tough week for for
everybody you know the firefighters
working hard on this fire residents of
course who have been evacuated it's it's
been a really challenging time today is
pretty Smoky and Yellowknife and
unfortunately it's pretty hot so that
can um cause some problems for the fires
the potential for flare-ups Crown so the
fire jumping from tree to trees so it'll
be a challenging 48 hours for the
firefighters
okay do you foresee people trying to
return early I know people are anxious
to get back home and if so what are you
planning to do to prevent them from
entering areas because of course the
area is still under an evacuation order
yeah exactly so um the fire is still a
threat to Yellowknife and the
territorial government's evacuation
order is still in place and there is
um a clause in that the legislation that
says you know if you do enter
um this evacuation order there are
penalties fines Etc we haven't really
had many many people looking to return
from the south of course everybody wants
to
um but in practice we haven't seen that
we've seen more from folks in
communities around Yellowknife who've
had some supply chain issues looking to
come to Illinois for grocery shopping
but not necessarily yellowknifers who
have tried to drive back up
will you be I mean enforcing having
enforcement there while people if people
do try to come back up
there is a check stop on the highway so
the Highway South is open folks can go
but the highway North there is a check
stop so the RCMP I believe are the ones
that are Manning that and that's um in
the the South slave area in the
Enterprise so
um yeah again folks please stay where
you are you're safe there the fire is
still a threat to Yellowknife here mayor
Rebecca alte joining us from her office
in Yellowknife where she's been all week
thank you so much for your time
not a problem thank you
Ontario Premier Doug Ford says he's
confident nothing criminal happened when
his government removed land from a
protected green belt for Housing
Development it's the first time we've
heard from Ford since the RCMP announced
it would assess whether to investigate
the deal
if they decide to investigate they
haven't decided yet but if they do I
take it very serious extremely serious
and I have zero tolerance if there's any
any nonsense going on
the auditor general found developers who
owned 15 sites of land removed from the
Green Belt just last year now stand to
see property values Rise by over 8
billion dollars
British police say they're investigating
the deaths of 88 people who brought
products from canadian-based websites
allegedly offering lethal substances to
people at risk of harming themselves
the probe centers around several
International inquiries sparked by the
arrest of a Mississauga man named
Kenneth law earlier this year police
allege he used a series of websites to
Market and sell sodium nitrate a
substance commonly used to cure meats
that can be deadly if it's ingested
it is an image that will be seared into
the history books Donald Trump is the
first former American president to have
a mug shot after he surrendered at
Atlanta's main jail on Thursday he's
accused of leading a criminal conspiracy
to overturn Georgia's 2020 election
results yet the infamous New Image could
be a powerful tool in Trump's bid to
retake the presidency Jackson prosco is
in Atlanta Jackson what's the political
calculus here pharah Donald Trump knew
he would be photographed when he turned
himself in Thursday night reports
suggest the former president decided he
wanted to project an image of defiance
with his mug shot knowing the picture
would instantly be shared across the U.S
and around the world within minutes of
its release Trump's team was
merchandising the photo to fundraise
selling T-shirts and seeking online
donations to the campaign now there's a
tinge of irony here because they're
using the photo with the tagline Never
Surrender ignoring the fact that the
picture was only taken because Trump
surrendered on those charges of
racketeer in conspiracy but Trump knows
small-time donors buy his
unsubstantiated claims of political
persecution and from his perspective
that one photo is the perfect tool for
building a comeback even if it looks
unpresidential
it's already becoming very clear that
the mug shot has increased his support
once again and will encourage at least
some of them to give even more money to
him among Republicans uh twice as many
people are more inclined to support him
strongly now like so many things in
American politics that image Cuts both
ways Trump's opponents will use it as a
stark reminder of the crimes he's
accused of namely trying to overturn an
election he lost you can expect to see
ads highlighting the fact that he's the
only presidential candidate facing the
prospect of jail time
how it all lands with voters will likely
be split down party lines some will see
it as proof that the law applies evenly
to all even a former president while
many of Trump's supporters will likely
see evidence of Trump's claims that he's
the victim of unfair prosecution
pharah Jackson prosco in Atlanta thank
you Jackson Hawaii's lean power provider
gets jolted with another lawsuit coming
up the mounting accusations over the
catastrophic wildfires
thank you
the county of Maui is now suing Hawaii's
biggest electricity provider for civil
damages after those deadly wildfires
that destroyed the town of Lahaina
the suit alleges the Hawaiian Electric
Company inexcusably kept their power
lines energized that's despite warnings
high winds could knock them down and
Spark fires it also accuses the provider
of lacking safety plans to shut off
power the for-profit companies serving
95 percent of Hawaiians is also facing
several lawsuits from residents and
investors over the disaster
so far 115 people are confirmed dead
from the tragedy and there are fears
that that number is going to increase on
Thursday Maui officials released the
names of 388 people still unaccounted
for hoping to learn more about their
whereabouts
we do know that once those names come
out it can and will cause pain but we
want to make sure that we are doing
everything we can possibly
to make this investigation the most
complete thorough
to date
the number is a sharp drop from earlier
this week when the FBI reported more
than a thousand people were still
missing there was Eric Sorensen reports
many questions remain about how this
tragedy unfolded
power line just went down as the first
fires burned on the outskirts of Lahaina
Shane true couldn't know how inadequate
his garden hose would be you get all
this wind blowing and now you gotta fire
it just that was viewing this in a
matter of minutes in spite of Wind and
Fire warnings authorities were not
prepared and have been on the defensive
ever since Maui's mayor this week said
he was unaware of the extent of the
crisis as it unfolded I can't tell you I
can't tell you what contributed to what
as hurricane winds intensified east of
Maui the dry grasslands were a perfect
fuel for any spark blown by the winds
down into Lahaina it all happened so
quickly at 9 00 a.m on August the 8th
that small morning fire was declared
under control at 9 26 a warning was
issued for Hurricane winds Electrical
Workers couldn't keep up with power
lines coming down by 3 30 multiple fires
had flared up evacuations had begun at 4
45 fires were burning in many
neighborhoods for hour residents
desperately tried to escape at 9 45 PM
the Coast Guard was rescuing people
who'd fled into the ocean by midnight
fires were out of control Lahaina was
being utterly destroyed many residents
received no warnings sirens in the
community were left silent do you regret
not sounding the sirens I I do not the
fire chief said those Sirens primarily
for tsunami warnings could have sent
people running towards the Flames he
later resigned we're not stupid we know
what a fire looks like as downed power
lines sparked fires the utility kept the
power on turning it off would have
disconnected vital Communications the
governor says there is a lot to
investigate we will get to the bottom of
exactly how the fire started how our
emergency procedures and protocols need
to be strengthened it now appears early
fires were not properly mopped up the
disaster is a hard lesson and not just
for officials in Hawaii it's a ticking
Time Bomb ubc's Dwayne Tennant is an
expert who had his own front front row
seat to the recent fires in Kelowna he
says governments everywhere must do more
to manage grass and Woodlands near
communities that will increasingly fuel
wildfires rather than constantly being
reactive and and dealing with
emergencies but we need to be able to
control the severity of these fires by
engaging in fuel management back in Maui
officials are under intense scrutiny
once again as they look now for the dead
Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
a brand for kids
the Spanish government has started legal
proceedings to suspend its soccer
Federation chief after his unsolicited
kiss following Spain's Women's World Cup
win
Luis ribialis is under Fire for kissing
star player Jenny hermoso on the lips
while handing out medals on Sunday he
says the kiss was consensual hermoso
says it was not some members of the team
say they will not play until rubialis
has been removed from his job
one of the most recognizable tissue
brands in Canada is about to make a
clean exit the maker of Kleenex tissue
says it will stop selling the product
here this month but will still serve the
professional Market its corporate parent
says the brand has been faced with
unique complexities in this country
the faces beyond the Flames next the
personal stories of those enduring BC's
harsh Wildfire season
the reopening of a section of Highway 1
in BC's shoe swap region was a major
sign of success there but officials also
confirmed today that more than 130
structures have been lost Jamie Dahl is
in the region speaking to those who are
still fighting and who refuse to leave
another night living on fast food and
going nowhere fast in a box store
parking lot how many trucks
I brought six you brought six trucks
yeah how did you Corey Tomlin will
eventually be returning home with a lot
more than his trucks his cat went into
labor and had four kittens while he was
fleeing maybe the stress I guess
and on day two of living in this Salmon
Arm parking lot his dog delivered 11
poppies really stressful we just want to
go back home it's been one week since
fire raced over these mountains invading
communities forcing hundreds from their
homes the burden has been immense
oh a lot lots of stress
lots of stress this man has been
fighting to keep his house safe while
trying to visit his 101 year old dying
father who passed away yeah that's
pretty tough yeah again unfortunately
he's in Cologne and we're here dealing
with this
what are you missing the most
power
yeah it's nice and quiet but you still
need power
on the other side of the lake the
communities of anglemont and St ice have
been cut off for a week and food is
starting to spoil the Community
Association is feeding the village doing
what it can we really need fresh produce
lettuce celery anything fresh I think
I've had like three nights of Mr Noodles
now
but it's tough to hold on to humor
surrounded by so much hardship I don't
have words to describe it
there's so much Devastation happening
right
we've been pretty lucky here but help is
on the way this barge is loaded down
with propane food and other supplies on
its way over to anglemon and Saint Ives
I know that there's some households
running out of food and it will be very
very important to get this in and we're
very excited nobody knows when normalcy
will return but they are sure over all
of this
Jamie dog Global News anglemont BC
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm foreign osser on behalf
of our whole crew here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your candidate
is Dows Lake in Ottawa we love senior
Canada so please keep emailing us your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
[Music]
thank you